you
[Music]
that's my great pleasure to introduce
David sonntag as our first speaker of
this session and actually I first met
him in New York when we were both of NYU
so I now notice that you are now with
MIT as an assistant professor and ya
already yet when I was with NYU I was
where we yeah impressed by how he
applies way and justing innovator of
machine learning techniques to a domain
that we probably at some now at some
point care about and that is healthcare
and yeah I'm looking forward to see what
you're working on these days well thanks
very much for the organizers for
inviting me in fact they didn't invite
me they invited Anika Rahman scan to
give this talk they invited me to give
another talk but Anna unfortunately
couldn't make it today she has a young
baby at home and so today I'll be taking
her place to talk about this work it's
joint work between myself
you seemed your knight who was a PhD
student of mine at NYU and Anika Rahman
ski Karolinska and really you've seen
did the chunk of these slides he
couldn't make it either
but I really credit should go to him so
and this work had appeared in our ICML
2017 paper so the high-level questions
as follows how can we do extreme
classification quickly right this is the
topic which has been discussed already
quite a bit this morning and for us
we've been very much motivated by
language modeling
although the techniques I'll tell you
about today will be really applicable to
many other settings such as
classification so in language modeling
we would like given given some text to
learn a distribution over tax such that
we could model for example draw the new
sentence from the model or we could ask
given some existing words what's the
likelihood of seeing
of the next word so let's look at this
simple example here the rat scared the
cat so if we had just seen the first
four words the rat scared uh we might
ask what is the likelihood of the next
word in that sentence in this case
capped well by the chain rule any set of
words w1 through WN the distribution
over them could be factorized as the
probability of word 1 probability of
word 2 given word one probably Ward 3
given water one comma word 2 and so on
just by the chain rule so in order to
compute that each each conditional
likelihood we need to get some
distribution over the next word given
all the previous words neural language
models typically summarize those
previous words with some context vector
in this case will refer to it as a V
context and it might for example be done
by taking word embeddings for each of
the words in the previous in the
sentence pushing them through a
recurrent Network and looking at the
hidden state at the last word which in
this case is that and that would
summarize all of the previous words in
some d dimensional vector and given that
d dimensional vector then the question
is ok what is that next words we want to
predict one class out of a class of size
the whole vocabulary which could be in
the millions now often that conditional
distribution of that last word P cannot
give in the context V the rot scared
that would be parameterize dwith a
softmax function so it would look
something like this
where we say that for every word in the
vocabulary we have some vector so that's
here denoted as a UW which is also D
dimensional and then the conditional
distribution of W given the context has
just given to you by a renormalization
of the exponential dot product of the
context with that word vector u v UW
renormalized
so that we have a valid distribution
over all possible words and this is
nothing new this is this is the standard
approach to language modeling that's
used across natural language processing
now to compute that numerator for
example that that exponential term
it takes running time order D where D is
the dimensionality of that context and
word embedding but in order to compute
the full conditional distribution we
need that denominator as well right so
it's going to be order D time to compute
each of these terms and then the
denominator is going to be order D times
V the vocabulary size running time
because we have to sum over all possible
words in the vocabulary to get a valid
distribution over the vocabulary and
that's the problem right so that that
ends up being one of the main
bottlenecks for learning neural language
models so there's been a number of
approaches in the NLP community for
trying to address this bottleneck during
training you might have heard of things
like negative sampling self normalizing
models and Haruko softmax and in our
work we're going to be focused on that
last approach howard google's softmax
one of the really nice things about this
hierarchical softmax is that it gives us
a valid language model so we can exactly
compute the probability of any next word
in the sentence and it's going to be
fast not just at training but also at
test time that some of the other
approaches might not have so what is
this hierarchical softmax I'm talking
about
well the key idea is rather than
describing the distribution over all of
the words using a soft max we're going
to predict first we're going to in
essence follow the trajectory through a
tree and only when we get to the leaf of
the tree well we know what is the word
that we want to predict and at each step
we're going to be just making binary or
in our work it'll be a merry decisions
and so the total running time in order
to make a prediction is going to be much
smaller than the vocabulary size
potentially logarithmic in the
vocabulary size so let's see how this
works so let's stick with a previous
example we want to figure out given that
context what is the likelihood of the
next word being cat well the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to look
at the root of the tree
and we're gonna ask what is the
likelihood of branching in this case
it's a three area tree so what's the
likelihood branching to n2 as being the
next step in this procedure and we're
going to I'm going to be asking about
each one of these steps until you get to
the leaf corresponding to the label
count so we're going to factorize we're
going to stipulate that the distribution
of cat' given the context is now going
to be factorized as each decision that
has to be made to get you that leaf so
first probability of n2 given and 1 then
probability of n4 given n2 then probably
of cat' given n4 and if you multiply it
you could each of the probabilities
together you get the overall likelihood
of getting to the label cat and you can
now imagine a generative process where
we want to sample a new word given this
conditional context we're going to
sample from that first distribution and
sort of work our way through that tree
to we get to the leaf so the running
time then goes from well each at each
decision it takes running time d times m
where m is again the branching factor of
this tree d is the dimensionality of the
of the context and if the tree is of
depth log law of V the vocabulary size
meaning it's a balanced tree then the
running time is now logarithmic in in
the vocabulary size in or it's a sample
from the conditional distribution or to
estimate the conditional likely of a
particular label in this case the label
again corresponds to a word in the
vocabulary so this hierarchical softmax
is widely used in an LP
but the question which everyone in the
community always asks is what should
that tree be what is it structure where
is it coming from and there been a
number of approaches to try to address
that question the first one has been one
of clustering so for example you might
use off-the-shelf algorithm like or
Tyvek to learn some word embeddings and
then do some clustering of these word
embeddings to get a candidate tree and
then train that parameters of that tree
or maybe iterate this procedure
in some way in order to try to find
trees that are semantically meaningful
that words that might be words that
might have sing similar meetings maybe
are in similar locations along the along
the bottom of the tree so so that's one
approach another approach that's widely
used is is based on Huffman coding which
is completely wacky except that it works
so this Huffman coding idea says that
we're going to completely ignore the
semantics of what the of what these
labels are we're just going to try to
learn a tree structure such that very
fruit frequent label and this won't be a
balanced tree very frequently occurring
labels are high up in the tree and not
so frequently incurring labels or low
entry so that if you were to completely
ignore the contacts and just ask the
question of what's the expected number
of branches you need to do to get to a
word it's there as low as possible and
finally it an even more recent work for
example we've used this in my own lab
people have just gone for random
hierarchies just giving up on anything
and just saying okay we're going to
randomly create a tree so for example in
my work I've used serve a square root V
tree where we have a square root V
branching and then and it's and then
it's not very deep and so we just
randomly assign words to the Leafs and
learn a model and that also seems to
work reasonably well but but this leaves
the open the question okay these things
all work reasonably but well but what is
there still to be gained right if we
were to actually try to think hard about
this problem and learn that tree
structure could we do better and this is
one of the first works to really address
that problem and the conclusion I'll
just tell you that now the conclusion is
that there is a gap
in performance that that you substantial
gap in performance between either the
clustering based approaches or the
Huffman coding based approaches and the
flat softmax and by cleverly learning
that tree structure we completely
eliminate that gap that's the conclusion
while still attaining most of the
computational speed ups so how do we get
there well there's been quite a bit of
earlier work on learning tree structures
in similar settings notably by harmonica
and John Langford sitting here and that
itself built on uneven earlier work by
by Kearns and mentor but they considered
settings where there was no whether
there was no where the contacts were
unchanging so for example if you think
about a typical bag of words
classification setting where we have a
fixed feature vector representation
we're just trying to learn how to
predict from a large number of classes
what the what the class should be then
then those algorithms would apply but
here the story's a little bit different
because remember when you're learning a
language model you're not just learning
this tree structure and the but you're
also learning the the recurrent neural
network parameters as well right so you
have to learn the word embeddings had to
learn the parameters of your gates and
so on and so what that means is that the
representation of your context are
changing as well during your learning
algorithm and what we don't want to do
is a two step algorithm where you fix
the representation and learning the tree
and then alternate we want it what we
want to ask in this work is is there a
way to jointly learn everything and so
we're going to give an algorithm to do
so we're going to provide very weak
theoretical guarantees so we have some
theory in our paper but really it leaves
a lot to be desired and but we do show
that that this works very well in
practice and we're going to evaluate
this in both the language modeling
setting and in
an extreme classification setting so our
overall approach will actually be a
little bit similar to how you attack
call learning a decision tree all right
so if you think about learning decision
tree you might think about some criteria
for how you would build that decision
tree you think about things like purity
or or accuracy as measures for how to
choose the next split and you might
build that decision tree in a top-down
fashion we're going to give you the same
sort of objective here except it's going
to be a little bit different to take
into consideration some of the
subtleties of this problem and and our
learning algorithm won't be a greedy
top-down algorithm it's going to have
steps in it of fitting the language
model completely redoing the tree and
alternating and what we're going to show
and is that using this objective leads
to good trees so here's now where I get
into some of the details so first I
never I told you how we branch so let's
first look at the setting of just two
classes we'll call it the the class for
the word lost in the 1/4 time suppose we
have some data where here the data
consists of sentences that give you
relevant context for which you would
like to predict to that next word and
that's suppose that next word was lost
or time so if we just had two classes
then our trees just going to be a binary
tree of depth one where we only have to
make one decision go left or go right in
order to get to one of these two classes
and so there one could use just a
sigmoid function where you take that
context and you and you hit it with this
linear classifier parametrized by a
weight vector H and that gives you some
distribution according to the sigmoid or
logistic over-over which classes the
right class for that context and if you
had more than two classes that is to say
if rather than a binary this were an MRE
tree
this would done you would just use a
soft max instead and so then that can
give you the probability that get then
gives you the probability of each one of
these classes given the relevant context
so so now suppose that you have more
than two classes and again I'm gonna for
this example I'm gonna stick with an
equals two so a binary tree but in the
in our experiments we'll would go with
up to seventy sixty five so so now the
stories can be as follows
consider the following data point I ate
some gives you some context this is how
we do prediction so not learning but
just prediction supposing that we have a
learned model we start at the root the
root node is associated with some some
parameters in this case since it's a
binary tree there's just a single
hyperplane we're doing you were using
linear splits that hyperplane tells us
by taking the dot product of the
hyperplane with that context vector it
decides to go left to go right then here
so you go left you make the similar
decision now for node n to node n for
and eventually you get to your
prediction which is the label pi right
so then the likelihood of pi is just
given to you by the product of each one
of those soft maxes of the decisions
needed to make to reach that label so
now let's ask the question of how do we
learn that tree structure well we gave
an objective an objective function which
will quantify how good the split at any
one node is and then our overall
objective function is going to be the
sum of those per node objectives so now
I'll tell you what each of those per
node objectives is for each node n in
your tree and again this is an emery
tree with with with K overall classes
where K remember it could be something
like if this was a vocabulary it would
be a real capillary size so for each
node in the tree we're going
look to see first what are the
distribution of classes that reach that
node in the tree its if you were to if
you were to imagine a prediction which
where each data points or follows its
way down in this case we're going to
look at the path from the from the root
to the leaf corresponding to the correct
label for that data points class and so
we're going to look at all of the data
points that reach some corresponding
intermediate node along the path from
the root to its correct label and that
will give you the distribution Qi and
obviously if Q if this distribution Qi
is very Peaks to one class then you're
basically there you basically know what
the right class is and if this is a
uniform distribution then you're very
uncertain and your goal here of course
just like with learning any type of
decision tree is to make this bs peaked
as possible meaning you're making
progress towards figuring out what the
right classes and so in this example
here we have four classes and for
exactly this might be the root and then
we say this is this Q just gives us the
distribution of data points that reached
that corresponding node with that class
now the next quantity of relevance is
going to be measuring now that you know
which nodes with what which example is
which what labels reach this node where
are they sent to next right which child
is R is it going to and that's going to
be essential for characterizing how good
is the splits at this node and for this
we're going to measure that by this
conditional distribution P of J given I
where the conditional we're conditioning
on examples of each class eyes we're
going to just look at data points of
some class and then ask what is the
distribution of data bunch of that class
that go to each child and intuitively
again we want this to be we want each of
these conditional distributions to be as
peaked as possible which means that
we're surrounding the data points in an
optimal way and here where we're using a
soft max to make those routing decisions
this is just given to you by the
following expectation
and finally we can put those two pieces
together PJ given AI and Q of AI to get
P of J which is simply the average the
fraction of examples that go to child I
of this corresponding node now this is
just a summary of the three things the
three definitions I gave you and using
those three definitions now we have our
overall objective which is given on the
very bottom here so the objective for
node n is a sum over the Qi where again
Qi is summing over all possible classes
or labels and then a sum over the
children of that node of PJ minus PJ
given AI right and so we want this to be
as high as possible where as high as
possible means sort of this average
quantity we would like all of that mass
to be honest part on to be to be routed
towards a single child for each class
now this has a number of properties so
for example what one can show is one
could define this notion of of purity
alpha N and one can show that this
objective function correlates with with
with good purity namely that if you were
to maximize as objective as much as
possible it would lead toward toward
splits that are pure moreover one could
characterize another notion of balance
how much are we balancing across this or
the the classes are along the tree and
once again one can show that you can
maximize this objective as much as
possible it also leads to good balance
so in our paper we have some theoretical
results which motivate those two
properties I just gave
and also show that if you were to that
it that there exist trees that that are
not too large that satisfy these
properties so our overall learning
algorithm is then as follows we're going
to have this is going to be a batch SGD
algorithm and for each batch size of
examples we're going to completely redo
the tree structure and we're going to
find we have a greedy algorithm which
chooses the new tree structure that is
to say relabeling each of the leaves
with new new classes that we show is
greedily maximizing the derivative of
the sum of these node objectives with
respect to our model parameters subject
to well forming this constraints and so
for each batch we're going to first
completely redo the tree structure then
we're going to take gradient steps with
respect to the model parameters so that
recur neural network the word embeddings
and also the split parameters now
importantly each one of these steps both
choosing the new tree structure and
model optimizing the parameters of your
language model are all optimizing the
same objective function and so that
really starts to get at this goal of
having a unified objective that deals
with both the fact that the
representations are changing and the
fact that we want to find really good
trees so here's an example what it looks
like
suppose we see a new example for this
class was we figure out what is we look
in the current tree to see what it what
it would leaf it's that we compute the
gradient of this objective for every
node along the path from the root to its
true label we can update node statistics
we take a gradient step and then we
update the tree structure and so here
you'll see us or a global change like
this where pi moves from the far right
hand side
we do a new split we get this new tree
structure and we iterate so just the
remaining two minutes I'm going to talk
a bit about how this algorithm does in
practice so first we looked at a
language modeling problem where we took
large corpora from the Gutenberg Project
as 15 million word corpus we use a
vocabulary of size 250,000 so they're
two hundred thousand classes here we're
trying to predict and for this work we'd
used a really simple log bilinear and
gram neural language model we learned a
m equal 6565 Airy tree of depth three
and what I'm showing here is a little
bit hard to see but I'm showing is the R
is the tree structure that's learned and
visualized in terms of what are the
classes the most frequent classes that
are underneath each node of the tree to
try to get a sense of whether we're
actually learning whether there's any
interesting semantic grouping of the
classes that's learned by this algorithm
and indeed we see that so for example on
the far right we see that the classes
this these those and so on or group
together over here we see through
classes is put set and they cut or group
together and so on but more importantly
than the semantics is really how it does
in practice it's real shame that these
plots aren't showing but I'll walk you
through whether what they're saying
this part of the left is the x-axis is a
box of training and the y axis is
perplexity or held out like or a measure
a measure of how tall likelihood and we
would want to be as small as possible so
this red line that you see up here is
the held out perplexity of using a
random tree this blue line that you can
see pretty clearly is the held out
perplexity of using a flat softmax so
it's going to be much slower to train
and use a test time because of the fact
that is not har quickly structured and
you see that there exists a pretty big
gap there although not showing you it
here the
fostering tree type of approaches close
to is actually worse than all of these
lines now the Green Line which is almost
impossible to see follow my I'm going to
show you it by following my cursor it
initially begins by somewhat being
similar to the random hierarchy until
roughly the second epoch of training
where it settles on a good heart a good
tree structure and from there on out
it's learning curve is identical to that
of the flat softmax so what we see here
is that by learning the tree structure
in fact we're able to fully recover the
quality of model that were able to get
using just a flaw flat softmax next we
looked at a text classification problem
where we actually modeled it almost
identically to to the density estimation
setting previously considered with the
only difference being that here to do
prediction we don't want a sample we
actually want to do map inference so for
prediction here we're going to be doing
a map inference for the for the class
which will which we do by simple branch
and bound with a depth-first search
through this hierarchical tree in order
to predict for each new example we
valued it on this Flickr tag
classification setting where the input
is an image like this and your goal is
to figure out sort of what are the tags
is that this that this input corresponds
to now most people use this data set to
try to predict the tags directly from
the image or to do something about
relating the image to the caption I want
to first point out that we could have
used this approach from the image of
itself right so one could imagine using
our algorithm to simultaneously learn
the parameters of a convolutional neural
network and a hierarchical softmax to
predict the class that would be a good
use case we wanted to stick with
language because this is something that
my students is more interested in and so
we didn't actually use the image of
stuff rather we use the text of the
caption and asked we predict the labels
the tags from the text of the caption
using a simple bag of words embedding
where we're somewhat Ainslie learning
the word in bed
at the same time and indeed the same
story applies here where the learned
tree that I'm showing you here here for
the areas five-and-twenty obtains
precision at one which is substantially
better than you could have gotten with a
Huffman tree or a couple of other base
line algorithm is that we compared to
you what's particularly interesting
however is that as the dimensionality of
your word embeddings increases that gap
seems to shrink so so that I think
that's something that's that's gonna be
interesting for us to think about in the
future in particular what this motivates
is that maybe this approach of learning
Harco softmax we're learning the
structure maybe that's most important in
settings where you're more resource
constrained where you can't afford to
have very large vocabulary is and so the
decisions that are sorry you can't defer
to have very large dimensionalities and
so the decisions that are made at each
step of the tree are hard and because
they're hard learning the tree structure
is more important so I'll just conclude
by saying this is one of the first works
to show how to learn the tree structure
of a haiku softmax
together with the underlying
representations there are a ton of open
questions particularly on the
theoretical side and there are some
interesting empirical work to be done
and some new directions there so just to
spear some interest there's really no
reason why we had to use a tree
structure model one could imagine using
a forest one could imagine using
allowing each class to appear a couple
of times in the in rather than just once
in the tree and one could even imagine
using the same sort of structure
learning algorithm for other deep
learning applications so thank you
okay thank you so we have maybe time
only for one or two quick questions if
there are any yep maybe this one and
then yeah so the questions about
applying Harville softmax for
multi-label classification
Oh naively this could be used there as
well I don't know the best way to do it
I had to think about it that's a really
interesting question said David's asking
whether whether the structure could be
reused well one of our original thoughts
is that the structure itself might be
interesting from a good linguistic point
of view particularly the language
modeling setting I don't think there's
evidence from our experiment results to
justify that statement a second question
is whether the structure can be reused
for other predictive problems and I
think that I think the short answer is
yes if the way that the representations
relate to the labels that you're
predicting is generalizable okay that's
thank our speaker I
[Applause]